so what I want to do here is dip my toe
in the water and have a discussion about
DC's injustice comics and assuming this
becomes popular enough then it may be a
series that we continue since the
injustice stories are some of the best
that DC has ever written
so the injustice comics come out of the
2013 injustice gods among us video game
for the Xbox one and the PlayStation 4
as well as various other platforms
because a video game series was so
popular garnering a rating of 80% or
better across the board due to the fact
that it presented a dystopian future
ruled by Superman and supported by other
superheroes the injustice comic line was
introduced as a way to capitalize on the
game's popularity by providing fans with
a prequel written by Tom Taylor who had
proved himself capable as a writer with
various Star Wars titles under Dark
Horse in addition to several musicals in
place during a 2013 interview with Comic
Vine Taylor had stated that writing this
series was as difficult as it was simple
while this seems contradictory what this
means is that because the injustice
video game had a plot in and of itself
centering on the Joker destroy
metropolis combined with the deaths of
Lois Lane and the unborn child of
herself and Superman the comic series
had to be written in a manner that
maintained the core element of the
game's plot but also provided clarity on
the events that transpired leading up to
the opening cinematic on the other hand
because the continuity of injustice was
separate from the new 52 which was
launched in 2011 Taylor had free reign
on the backstories of the characters as
well as the entire DC Universe as it
pertained to injustice meaning he could
introduce popular characters and teams
into the series while leaving out
unpopular characters and teams to this
end and justice vol 1 open by focusing
on the relationship between Clark Kent
and Lois Lane
leaving Superman's backstory open and
allowing the reader to fill in the
history of Clark by referencing any of
the previously established origin
stories Taylor maintained the element of
almost all Superman publications which
saw Lois Lane keeping his character
grounded what I mean here is that with
Superman hailing from an extinct race
with only fragments of their technology
in his possession while he was raised by
the Kent's on earth Superman himself was
effectively isolated and alone as the
last Son of Krypton Superman found
solace and the love that was shared
between himself and Lois and that while
their physiology separated the two in
the end she made him feel as if earth
was a home of his as a result over the
course of time a romance formed between
the two leading to a coupling and Lois
becoming pregnant was also funny about
this story is that Taylor focuses on
Clark's response to learning of Lois's
pregnancy by closing the gap between his
alien heritage
and what it means to be a father again
what I mean here is that like most
soon-to-be parents after learning of the
news Superman begins pacing back and
forth while focusing on the direction
that their lives will take after
bringing a child into the world for
Superman his identity as Clark Kent is
more important now than it has ever been
and while there are various people at
STAR Labs who can analyze Lois to ensure
that the baby will be born healthy the
other half of this equation is the city
of Metropolis itself while it is their
current residence and truth
Smallville West's first home on earth
and as such moving there would allow
both himself and Lois to raise their
child away from prying eyes as well as
attempted attacks from would-be
criminals seeking revenge on Lois for
any articles you may have written as a
journalist however while the two take
time to focus on the moment and revel in
the fact that they are pregnant Taylor
begins to set the stage for injustice by
having Lois his attention drawn to her
phone receiving an anonymous tip that a
member of the City Council is taking a
payoff at the metropolis stocks Lois
dresses herself for the purpose of
investigating and documenting the
transaction which can then be printed
allowing the councilman to be brought to
justice
transitioning to Batman Superman arrives
during which time were informed that a
piece of technology has been stolen from
STAR Labs while we're not told what it
is the purpose of this segment is to
establish the friendship that exists
between Bruce and Clark as a way to
demonstrate how far the two will fall
following the death of Lois and the
destruction of metropolis as a yin and
yang to each other
Superman is as much a jovial child as he
is a hardened warrior Batman on the
other hand is basically a big grump and
the chemistry between the two had led
them to become extremely close friends
something that becomes apparent when
Superman informs Batman that both Lois
and Clark want him to be the Godfather
of their child for those who are unaware
the position of Godfather or godmother
is one of an incredible honor and that
Superman is telling Batman that should
something happen to him and Lois Bruce
is being asked to look after his son and
ensure that he grows into the world and
becomes a man that can bring honor to
the memory of his parents now
transitioning to Lois herself after
arriving at the location provided by the
anonymous tipster with Jimmy Olsen in
tow the expectation of the two is that
the tip is fake due to the fact that
they've received multiple anonymous tips
in the past most of which never panned
out
however after spotting a shady
individual looking in the corner Jim
Olsen is shot through the lens of his
camera killing him in the process
revealing himself to Lois Lane we
learned that the tip was a setup by both
the Joker and Harley Quinn as the two
intended to kidnap Lois transitioning to
the next morning what Taylor does here
is leave it to us to fill in the blanks
with Superman arriving at the docks and
locating Jimmy's corpse along with a
Joker card the indication here seems to
be that Lois never came home resulting
in Superman setting out to find her by
traveling to the metropolis docks
with Jimmy Olsen dead the message is
clear Lois had been kidnapped by the
Joker and as in sighting Superman to
follow him now picking up with Batman at
STAR Labs we learned that the missing
items are several pieces of unidentified
equipment as well as kryptonite
while Batman's line of questioning to
the scientists indicates skepticism of
their intentions the scientist states
that their experimentation with
kryptonite was not malicious
instead they intended to see if it could
be used for scientific and medical
purposes like providing a power source
or curing diseases taking the detective
approach and demanding a list of
everyone who would have had access to
STAR Labs or knew that they were in
possession of kryptonite Batman has
suddenly met with the arrival of
Superman now during this segment tailor
establishes several important things
that tie into the history of Superman
and even the Justice League itself
within the injustice universe the first
is the significance of Lois in relation
to Clark referencing what we said
earlier about Lois keeping plot grounded
in many ways she was a drug of sorts and
in particular an emotional drug for
Clark he needs Lois as she serves to
remind him that he's not alone and that
in his desperation he has no concern
over the scientists learning about his
personal identity the second is that
with Superman begging Batman for help
Bruce calls in the full roster of the
Justice League and the reserves for the
purpose of finding Lois while some
individuals like green arrow and cyborg
questioned why the entire Justice League
is being called in to locate a person
who seems of little importance the
indication here is that no one other
than Wonder Woman in Batman are aware of
Superman's identity as Clark Kent or
that he's in a relationship with Lois
now that stands in stark contrast to
previous continuities where the Justice
League had divulge their identities to
one another in order to instill their
trust as well as ensure that each
member was able to protect the loved
ones of everyone else and so with Barry
Allen having searched the entire city of
Metropolis using his incredible speed
while he was unable to locate Lois he
did discover something worth bringing to
Batman's attention with STAR Labs
functioning as a science and
technological research group operating
globally in addition to their base of
operations in Gotham they also have a
base of operations in Metropolis
arriving at its location
Batman has led to the deceased body of
Jonathan crane also known as scarecrow
who seems to have been killed by the
Joker toxin following this Batman and
the rest of the league are informed by
Wonder Woman that one of the dockworkers
in Metropolis had ran as soon as he was
spotted using her Lassa which forces
those ensnared to tell the truth Wonder
Woman had learned that the Joker and
Harley Quinn had hijacked a submarine
and taken Lois Lane with them with
Superman overhearing this information
and responding by searching the waters
around metropolis he eventually located
the sub where he removes it from the
water and places it on land however once
he enters we find both Harley Quinn and
Joker wearing gas masks and working on
Lois Lane at the same time though
Superman begins to become woozy after
being exposed to the gases within and so
using the information that's been
established so far they gases within
appeared to be a variation of the fear
toxin used by the Scarecrow something
that's confirmed when Superman
hallucinates doomsday battling his foe
and taking to the sky and away from the
city but Joker and Harley Quinn used a
distraction to take their leave now
adding a bit of comedy to the story
which has been lacking this element so
far Harley Quinn puts up a bit of a fuss
over the fact that she's never had a
submarine before and as a result has
become very taken with it after giving
it the name Gunter however where most of
the stories depict the Joker insane and
nonsensical
in this story Tom Taylor kind of watched
this middle line and that the Joker
seems relatively sane and that he
recognizes that because of their actions
and kidnapping Lois the arrival of
Superman and the fact that the Justice
League constantly maintained contact on
their missions or the submarines sitting
on land it is highly likely the Justice
League will know exactly where they are
now from here this story doesn't
actually allow much in the way of
interpretation with the Joker and Harley
being captured by Hal Jordan followed by
the arrival of Wonder Woman bat
and the flash the Joker taunts Batman a
bit by referencing the fact that the
flash had brought him here while Taylor
doesn't really do much to expand on this
in truth this is likely just a
demonstration of the Joker going on one
of his inane rambles furthermore with
Batman discovering that the interior of
the submarine is filled with the
Scarecrow's fear toxin the intention of
Wonder Woman is to use her lasso on the
Joker to discover the location of Lois
Lane
due to the fact that none of them are
aware of Superman's hallucination
however because of Batman's experience
with the Joker Tom Taylor continues to
walk this kind of line with the Joker's
insanity by having Batman Ward Wonder
Woman off due to the fact that with the
Joker being insane there's no telling
what he would say in addition to this
because alas o requires those who are in
snared to tell the truth with the Joker
being insane there would be no way to
know if what he's saying is true since
his insanity makes it impossible for him
to tell the difference between what's
real and what's fantasy and so with the
conversation between Batman and the
Joker leading to Bruce realizing what's
going on we learned that when Lois was
kidnapped the Joker is surgically
planted a trigger inside of her body
moved a nuclear warhead from the
submarine to the heart of Metropolis and
set the trigger for the nuclear warhead
to Lois his heartbeat furthermore while
Superman would normally be immune to the
Scarecrow's fear toxin the Joker had
laced the toxin with the Kryptonite he
stole from STAR Labs which weakened
Superman and made him susceptible
leading to his hallucination of doomsday
following this after revealing to the
bomb will detonate once Lois his
heartbeat stops Batman comes to the
realization that Superman is not
battling doomsday and instead is
battling Lois switching to Superman
himself we find that he's taken doomsday
out of the atmosphere and into space
where the toxin wears off leading to him
realizing that he's just killed Lois and
so with her heart stopping and
detonating the warhead metropolis is
completely destroyed as its engulfed and
a nuclear explosion with that being said
we're going to bring this video to an
end and let me know if you guys are a
big fan of the injustice series I
personally think it's one of the best
stories of DC's written in decades with
that being said I will catch you guys
later peace